قرروا دوري المحترفين عندما قدموا هذا
العرض لشراء كيليان وبابي،
كان هناك شهية حادة في
جميع أنحاء أوروبا وكان ذلك بالفعل علامة
على القوة الاقتصادية التي يمكن أن
تدخل في المزايدة عليه
أم أنه لم يكن يريد أن يأتي
ولكن هل هناك  مقياس
تقريبًا لفكرة أن هذا هو
دوري التقاعد، وهو دوري للاعبين
في الثلاثينيات من العمر والذين لا يرغبون في
لعب كرة قدم تنافسية بعد الآن، هو أن هذا هو
التفكير وراء تقديم
العطاءات له مقابل عثمان أيضًا و  اللاعب
النيجيري الدولي حسنًا أولاً،
لا أعرف إذا كان لا يريد أن
يأتي ربما لا يريد أن يأتي الآن
لن أقول ذلك كما تعلمون، لقد
استبعد تمامًا أنه لم يلتق  لا أعتقد
أنه أدلى بأي بيان واضح بهذا
المعنى ولكن مرة أخرى تمامًا كما في حالة
الإعصار ورونالدو وكارين،
الدوري مفتوح للجميع ولكن
لن يضطر أحد إلى القدوم
إلى الدوري يورغن كلوب  لقد تحدث هذا الأسبوع
عن قلقه
بشأن النفوذ السعودي وأريد أن
أقتبس منه قوله إن
النفوذ السعودي هائل في الوقت الحالي،
وأسوأ شيء تقريبًا هو أن
فترة الانتقالات في المملكة العربية السعودية مفتوحة لفترة
أطول من أوروبا،
ما هو ردك؟  إلى ذلك، ما هو
رأيك في ذلك جيدًا، أعتقد أنه
أسوأ شيء، لا،
لا أعتقد أنه أسوأ شيء،
وأعتقد أن هناك أم، لقد
سمعت الكلمة المستخدمة التي
تعرفها نحن  "إننا نعطل الصناعة،
ورأيي البسيط في ذلك هو أننا
نعم، نحن نعطل الصناعة ولكننا
نعطلها لتعزيزها، فنحن
نضيف قيمة إلى الصناعة،
وكانت هناك دول أخرى تعرفها
لديها  لقد تأخرت
أم اه نقل ويندوز
أم ولا يهم أن تعرف أن
اللاعبين سوف ينظرون إلى السوق
مع ممثليهم
ويقررون أين يريدون الذهاب وإذا
كان ليفربول غير قادر على الاحتفاظ
بلاعبيه فليس لديه ما يفعله  مع أه كما
تعلم مع تعرف
أوقات الانتقالات المتأخرة لتركيا أو روسيا أو
أو الدوري السعودي للمحترفين أه جوردان
هندرسون قائد ليفربول نعم
القدرة على الاستحواذ على الدوري السعودي للمحترفين،
وهذا تغيير حقيقي في قواعد اللعبة
جعل الناس يجلسون  انتبه ولاحظ
وخاصة عندما تفكر في أن
البطولات الأوروبية ستقام في العام المقبل،
هل تعتقد أنها قدمت بيانًا كبيرًا
كونها قادرة على إغرائه عبر نعم كل
أم كل لاعب من لاعبي ماكي الذين
جذبناهم إلى الدوري أه
يصنعه  تصريح كبير جوردان آه على
المستوى الشخصي هو شخص
أعجبت به دائمًا آه لقد حاولنا
التوقيع معه عندما كان في سندرلاند آه كما
تعلم لتشيلسي لأنه
آه من أخلاقيات عمله في هذا الوقت نعم لقد قمنا
بالتحقيق ولكني  كانت لدي فكرة
لدور مختلف تعرفه بالنسبة له،
والذي لم يعتقد المدرب في ذلك الوقت
أنه سيكون جيدًا في هذا
الدور ولكننا أردنا إحضاره.
يجب أن أعرفه.  لقد علمت أنك
تتابعه عن كثب
إنه شخص مدروس
ويهتم بجميع القضايا
وأعتقد أنه استغرق بعض
الوقت للدراسة واتخاذ هذا القرار
كما تعلم فعل كريم بنزيمة أه
تعرف زواج رياض  إذن، هؤلاء أنت
تعرف لاعبين رفيعي المستوى يتمتعون
ببيئة مريحة
وتعرف
جيدًا من الناحية المالية أن يفعلوا ذلك، وقد
اتخذوا هذا القرار
لأن
جزءًا من الوحش التنافسي
باعتباري لاعب كرة قدم سابق، ولكن من
الوحش التنافسي هو الرغبة
للذهاب وشق طريق،
نعم مرة أخرى، هناك دائمًا
حافز اقتصادي بالطبع يجب أن يكون موجودًا، ولكنه
الرغبة في الذهاب وتجربة
شيء آخر ومعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانك إحداث
فرق، وأعتقد أن الأردن ضمن
هذه الفئة من الرغبة في ذلك  اذهب وأرى
ما إذا كان بإمكاني مساعدة هذا الدوري ليكون شيئًا
مميزًا